ça a pris un peu tout le monde par
surprise de l'ampleur
quelle saloperie elle est l'une des
cofondatrices d'une page facebook de
dénonciations anonymes d'inconduite
sexuelle
elle nous a demandé l'anonymat parce
qu'elle craint de possibles représailles
salle a été créé pour donner une parole
aux victimes pour qu'ils puissent
dénoncer leur agresseur
cette page mais notamment vers une liste
qui contient des centaines de noms tous
présentés comme de potentiels agresseurs
sans préciser le geste qu'il aurait
reproché là on a rajouté des niveaux des
degrés de gravité
une critique heures sortie on l'a écouté
pourront ajuster notre approche
elle est d'ailleurs ne pas souhaiter de
mal aux personnes nommées mais plutôt
vouloir protéger des victimes
potentielles
l'objectif de tout ça c'est vraiment
d'avoir une prise de conscience
sociétale tout le monde se questionne
présentement sur des comportements qui
ont pu avoir problématique moi même
c'est clair que ça témoigne d'un
problème social qui est pas réglé pour
cette sexologue
même si les réseaux sociaux ne sont pas
la voie idéale pour dénoncer cette
nouvelle vague de dénonciations demeure
légitime
c'est certain que ça peut être un enjeu
le fait de qui a des faux témoignages
par contre
l'enjeu le plus important ici c'est la
problématique que derrière tout ça le
fait que les violences sexuelles sont
encore très présentes dans la société
la responsable du compte considère elle
aussi que le risque d'une forte
délégation existe mais il est minime
selon elle il va y avoir des vies
gâchées
mais il y a des vies gâchées déjà d'un
côté comme de l'autre
je suis extrêmement content de voir que
les femmes continuent à dénoncer les
agressions sexuelles bien que la
chroniqueuse francine pelletier
comprennent les motivations derrière le
mouvement ce qu'elle considère comme un
tribunal populaire l'inquiète
il ya d'autres façons de faire en
commençant par s'adresser directement
aux gens aux hommes dans ce cas ci qui
soi-disant ont commis des d'aidé faute
adressez vous à eux d'abord plutôt que
de 2,2 décidé qu'ils ont ce que ce sont
des brebis galeuses que ce sont des
parias de la société
je pense qu'il ya une façon il ya une
justice élémentaire à respecter la
responsable du compte à qui nous avons
parlé confirme avoir déjà reçu
mises en demeure et certains à des
poursuites elle considère malgré tout
que l'action dé dénonciatrice demeurent
pertinentes et nécessaires
si mathieu papillon radio canada
montréal